[Aplausos]
[Música]
aguas cristalinas playas infinitas
selvas infranqueables paisajes que nos
trasladan a la mismísima representación
en vivo del paraíso amigos filipinas es
un país lejano y desconocido que sin
embargo ha tenido una enorme conexión
histórica con españa con españa y de
alguna manera también con muchos de los
países hispanos de américa latina'
dando al mundo la más hermosa elección
de diplomacia amigos esta ex colonia
española del sudeste asiático fue
durante más de tres siglos parte del
imperio español después tras la derrota
de las tropas españolas en 1898 frente a
las de eeuu las filipinas fueron
vendidas a la potencia norteamericana
por 20 millones de dólares lo que
vendría a suponer tan sólo teniendo en
cuenta la inflación unos 620 millones de
dólares de hoy y si en aquella época las
colonias se vendían como si se trataran
de terrenito cerca de la playa claro que
en este caso la venta y el precio
prácticamente fueron determinados por
los eeuu al fin y al cabo para eso
habían ganado la guerra
claro que lejos de lograr la
independencia o al menos mejorar su
autonomía con los eeuu al frente tampoco
llegó la libertad para los filipinos
para ser vendidas a los norteamericanos
las filipinas fueron regidas por estos
durante casi cinco décadas hasta que
finalmente en 1946 consiguieron su
independencia desde entonces la
trayectoria de este país no ha sido
precisamente un camino de rosas sino más
bien de espinas dictaduras corrupción
violencia y narcotráfico islamismo
filipinas aglutina un poco de todos los
problemas que acechan a países tan
lejanos como venezuela honduras e
incluso pakistán y ahora ahora tienen
adúlteros
rodrigo duterte es el actual presidente
filipino y bueno a pesar de haber sido
elegido democráticamente
digamos que poco nada tiene de demócrata
más bien todo lo contrario fijaos un
alcalde filipino en la lista de narcos
de duterte es asesinado de un disparo la
política de masacrarlos dirigida a los
pobres de filipinas la guerra contra las
drogas del presidente rodrigo duterte ha
causado más de 20.000 muertes desde 2016
si habéis escuchado bien estamos
hablando de ejecuciones extrajudiciales
en toda regla y es que de facto el
gobierno de filipinas las ha legalizado
ahora bien queréis saber más sobre este
lejano país queréis saber más sobre la
oscura figura de rodrigo duterte pues
atentos
filipinas un país de luces y sombras
lo primero lo primero de todo creo que
tiene que ser conocer un poco mejor el
país del que estamos hablando no os
parece y amigos ya os adelanto que
hablamos de un país bastante pero que
bastante particular por un lado hablamos
del primer país de toda asia tener una
constitución aprobada por un congreso
parcialmente elegido fue a finales del
siglo 19 justo en el corto periodo que
transcurre entre el fin del dominio
español y la invasión norteamericana fue
entonces cuando una efímera república no
reconocida internacionalmente conocida
como la red pública de mal olor
pero claro tras pagar 20 millones por
estas islas los norteamericanos tenían
muy pero que muy claro que estos
territorio les pertenecía así que no
tuvieron ningún reparo en emplear toda
la fuerza necesaria para terminar con
autoproclamada república cualquier apoyo
a la causa independentista era
considerado como una actividad criminal
y en 1906 por ejemplo las tropas
norteamericanas arrestaron y ejecutaron
a los miembros del último gobierno de la
república incluyendo a su presidente el
general marcarios a cayó la muerte nos
llegará a todos tarde o temprano así que
me presentaré con calma ante el señor
todopoderoso pero quiero decirles que no
somos bandidos ni ladrones como nos han
acusado los americanos sino miembros de
la fuerza revolucionaria que defendió
nuestra madre patria las filipinas larga
vida de la democracia y ojalá nuestra
independencia renazca en el futuro larga
vida a las filipinas
macario sakai amigos filipinas es un
país extremadamente diverso para que os
hagáis una idea sus 110 millones de
habitantes hablan ni más ni menos 10 170
lenguas distintas que follón claro que
ese no es ni de lejos su mayor problema
y es que veréis aunque hasta la crisis
del coronavirus este país ha estado 20
años sin sufrir un solo trimestre de
crecimiento negativo y a pesar de que
durante la última década el crecimiento
económico medio ha sido de casi el 6%
anual filipinas sigue siendo un país muy
pobre un país en el que la mayoría de la
población sigue anclada en la más
absoluta pobreza para que os hagáis una
idea hablamos de un país donde el
salario medio es de poco más de 200
dólares mensuales y que tiene como una
de sus principales fuentes de riqueza
los casi 30 mil millones de dólares que
más de 12 millones de filipinos
repartidos por todo el mundo envían en
remesas a sus familias cada año
y si a esta situación le añadimos encima
los problemas que tiene el gobierno para
controlar un país formado por más de
7.000 islas bocas infraestructuras y 170
lenguas distintas entonces entonces nos
encontramos con el caldo de cultivo
perfecto para el surgimiento de
actividades poco recomendables
amigos la pobreza y la falta de control
del gobierno y la justicia sobre una
buena parte del país ha convertido a
filipinas en uno de los mayores centros
asiáticos para el tráfico de personas y
también para el narcotráfico filipinas
no sólo es el mayor consumidor de
metanfetaminas y marihuana de la serie
tal sino también su mayor productor y
sabéis de dónde proceden la mayoría de
los cárteles que operan en el país pues
de china y creo que ya os podéis hacer
una idea de lo que esto supone al igual
que pasa en otros países no existen
estas mafias la violencia y la
inseguridad son un enorme problema en
torno a las mafias de los
estupefacientes se ha ido creando todo
un entramado de economía ilegal dedicado
también al tráfico de personas órganos
contrabando de todo tipo y prácticamente
a cualquier otra actividad delictiva por
supuesto la corrupción está casi
institucionalizada como una actividad
económica más
y evidentemente tal y como os podéis
imaginar la pobreza obligaba a muchas
familias a tener que echarse
literalmente en brazos de todas estas
mafias que operan en el país y es aquí
como veremos donde surge la figura del
tc un presidente caracterizado
básicamente por dos cosas mano dura muy
dura contra el crimen y promesas de
crecimiento económico entendiendo este
último como pegar un puñetazo en la mesa
y cambiar de socio estratégico
y es que veréis durante años filipinas
ha sido un país muy cercano a los eeuu
tanto que washington ha llegado a
calificar su relación con filipinas como
especial y de hecho se les considera
como uno de sus aliados estratégicos más
importantes de asia junto a países como
taiwán corea del sur o tailandia
sin embargo desde la llegada del
presidente de ute en 2016 el eje manila
washington ha ido girando cada vez más
hacia pekín especialmente los últimos
dos años
fijaos fijaos que cambio de 2017 luther
te dice que el presidente chino si le ha
amenazado con la guerra si filipina
realiza perforaciones petrolíferas abril
de 2018 el presidente de filipinas
rodrigo duterte dice que necesita china
xi jinping necesito a china más que a
nadie en este momento necesito a china
simplemente amo a xi jinping él entendió
entiende mi problema y está dispuesto a
ayudar así que debo decir gracias china
rodrigo duterte presidente de filipinas
y es que vamos a ver duterte quiere
dinero inversiones capital chino
mansalva para levantar la economía del
país se puede decir más alto pero no más
claro
fijaos nuestro destino recae en asia no
en oriente medio pues están demasiado
ocupados peleándose y no tienen dinero
si tú no tienes dinero no eres mi amigo
así que acudo a china llena de dinero
rodrigo duterte presidente de filipinas
sorprendido de tanta sinceridad pues yo
deberíais tu parte es de todo menos un
presidente normal
y bueno en cierto modo es bastante
lógico que si es mejor con dictadores
como sí que con los líderes de las
democracias occidentales que porque pues
atentos
[Música]
verte el presidente más bestia si algo
ha caracterizado a rodrigo juntarte
desde el principio de su presidencia es
que es un presidente que habla claro y
que no se anda con chiquitas digamos qué
escrúpulos lo que siete escrúpulos pues
no tiene está dispuesto a hacer lo que
haga falta para luchar no sólo contra el
tráfico de estupefacientes y los
delincuentes sino también contra sus
adversarios políticos de hecho sus dudas
formas le han hecho granjearse la fama
en medio mundo de dictador de tirano de
no respetar los más básicos derechos
humanos sin ir más lejos miras por
ejemplo lo que ha ocurrido durante la
crisis del sars coronavirus 2 tú te
prometió hacer cumplir a rajatabla las
40 y nacidos toques de queda a cualquier
precio
la respuesta de duterte al coronavirus
dispararles a matar mis órdenes a la
policía y al ejército si estáis en
problemas o la situación escala y pone
en peligro vuestra vida dispararles a
matar entendiste jce a matar lo enviaría
a la tumba no pongáis a prueba al
gobierno dos días después de estas
declaraciones un granjero de 63 años fue
tiroteado por la policía por no llevar
mascarilla según los agentes el hombre
les amenazó con una guadaña
proporcionalidad qué demonios es eso de
esta forma a lo largo y ancho del país
se ha reportado un incremento de los
tiroteos entre policías y civiles algo
que por otra parte no juntan las fuerzas
del orden cualquier persona que salga en
el momento equivocado recibirá un
disparo hijos de oficial de la policía
filipina en la radio y no sólo eso
siguiendo las propias órdenes del
gobierno en algunos municipios se ha
encarcelado en jaulas para perros a las
personas que eran pillada saltándose los
toques de queda en otros lugares también
se han aplicado castigos que fácilmente
podrían confundirse con torturas claro
que un momento porque este tipo de cosas
no empezaron ni mucho menos con el
coronavirus
tuitert es un tipo que simple y
llanamente lo crean la reinserción según
él mismo ha expresado en muchas
ocasiones que las personas que cometen
delitos no son más que desechos sociales
prescindibles
precisamente por eso duterte estableció
una política de cero tolerancia contra
los traficantes y los consumidores de
estupefacientes desde su llegada al
poder ordenó también disparar a matar
y ojo pensando un momento más allá de
que todo esto suponga una clara
violación de los derechos humanos más
elementales y que la experiencia nos
diga que esta no es la mejor forma de
luchar contra el crimen lo que twitter
te ha hecho es simple y llanamente poner
en marcha toda una maquinaria de
ejecuciones extrajudiciales le ha dado a
la policía a muchos funcionarios
públicos y a su propio gobierno la
capacidad de quitarse de en medio con
total impunidad a muchas personas todo
esto además en un país con altos niveles
de corrupción y despotismo
te hago una pregunta te atreverías en un
escenario como este a llevar la
contraria al gobierno oa denunciar por
ejemplo los tejemanejes de algún oficial
de policía apuesto a que no
[Aplausos]
desde que se puso en marcha está bestial
política de 'tolerancia cero' de
legalidad cero mejor dicho se estima que
han perdido la vida en filipinas al
menos seis mil 600 personas según la
policía cifra que human rightswatch
aumenta hasta los 27 mil 27 mil personas
para colmo muchas de estas personas no
tenían nada que ver con el narcotráfico
ni con las mafias ni con ninguna
actividad criminal sino que simplemente
eran personas que sencillamente fueron
víctimas del fuego cruzado o de la
corrupción entre otros motivos
ahora bien llegados a este punto como
pensáis que valoran los filipinos a este
presidente pues amigos la popularidad de
rodrigo duterte ronda el 80 el 80 por
ciento vamos que es poco menos que un
fervor popular pero como demonio es un
tipo semejante puede cosechar estos
niveles de aprobación
[Música]
es bueno puede parecer difícil de asumir
en nuestra cultura pero en unas
filipinas golpeadas por el crimen del
tráfico de estupefacientes el tráfico de
personas y la pobreza no es extraño que
para muchas personas cosas como la
libertad y los derechos humanos queden
en un segundo plano de hecho según las
propias encuestas apenas el 15% de los
filipinos consideran que la democracia
es esencial al final pasa lo que ya
hemos conocido un montón de veces la
desesperación los desengaños y la
corrupción suelen ser las mejores vías
para alimentar a los líderes
autoritarios
en fin llegados a este punto turno para
ti está legitimado un presidente como
duterte a saltarse los derechos humanos
incluso si persigue un fin que a priori
puede ser bueno y está la lucha contra
el crimen por encima de la ley y la
justicia queréis que alguien como usted
podría caer bien en vuestros países
dejarnos aquí abajo vuestros comentarios
y si os ha gustado este vídeo no
olvidéis darle al botón de like
suscribiros a nuestro canal y por
supuesto darle a la campanita para estar
al tanto de todas nuestras novedades una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]